president biden has some big problems
the commander-in-chief limping towards
the end of his first year in office
bruised and battered on pretty much
every issue and now voters are blaming
him 47 percent think the president's
making inflation worse and surging
prices under his watch are taking a huge
bite out of your wallet it's going to
cost households an extra 3 500 this year
alone
so it's no wonder democrats are being
advised to dump the guy there's growing
speculation about biden's true 2024
plans he keeps telling people he will
take another run but some in the liberal
media are telling him sit it out
and ari fleischer thinks it would be the
kiss of death for the democratic party
if biden runs again listen
there is no chance he's running for
reelection he's going to be an unpopular
president he's going to be 80 after the
november election next year and the
american people are just not going to go
and the democratic party aren't going to
going to go for an 82 year old candidate
and now kamala harris is claiming she
and biden have not even talked about
running for reelection because you know
they're too focused on other issues dana
perino
do you believe her
is this even conceivable i it is
conceivable yes but i think that what is
interesting is that her instinct wasn't
to say
absolutely he should run again right
we have an amazing record she left the
door we did what we said we were going
to do we have a lot more like i mean
there are so many ways that she could
have said absolutely and been his like
biggest champion and so he's like
actually no it was like super awkward
yeah super awkward i think that they're
ending this year on a as this is a
bloomberg headline not just my words on
a very sour note um the things that they
wanted to get done are not getting done
their poll numbers are really low they
have incredible amounts of dysfunction
within the party and disagreements and a
lot of them are blaming joe manchin just
because he won't approve the number but
this bill actually had so many other
things that they hadn't even solved yet
the immigration piece wasn't solved the
salt taxes weren't solved there was many
other pieces of it that couldn't get
past the fact that joe manchin said i
don't think that throwing a bunch more
money into the system is a good way to
help the american people the inflation
numbers if you get 70 percent of the
american people to agree
that a pr a president is not doing well
on the issue that matters most to you
you're in trouble yeah and judge 3 500 a
year for the average family that is a
huge amount of money 3 500 for the same
products that you had last year you're
not getting anything new you're just
spending more and it's cutting into your
your savings and whatever plans you
might have had to maybe take care of the
kids to maybe take a vacation everything
is negative but you know i have to tell
you what's interesting about kamala uh
dana when you were talking about her is
she said you know we haven't talked
about it we're not even in a year yet
and we're in the middle of a pandemic
and you know my question then is well
what have you done about the pandemic
that you can claim is good i mean
there's nothing that they've done in
these 11 months that is positive in any
way shape or form the only positive
thing
is joe manchin
joe manchin is going to save the
democrats from themselves by not
allowing them to do the build back
better bill because that will then put
the democrats in a position where it's
not going to be 69 percent of americans
who are upset with inflation it's going
to be 99 of the americans do you think
have you ever seen this early in a first
term everybody and not just the
democrats but the mainstream media
basically tell the incumbent you're done
well i think first of all arie fleischer
should be ashamed of himself for that
elder abuse i took it very personally
you did i did i mean just uh he made
made it sound like uh joe's stepping out
of the grave to show up at the oval
office every day um
but seriously he's not he's not coherent
that's what that was about not even he's
only eight months older than us but
you're looking you're quick you're with
us come on you're different i i think
that what's happening seriously is a
coveted malaise
i really believe that if we had been
beating the disease this holiday season
people would be upbeat i just heard uh
from my my second daughter she's tested
positive she was at a party with 200
kids at yale
it's it's something that preoccupies
everybody so in everything you know
with the cost of of living going up with
uh
you know the holiday season the
uncertainties of the disease and so
forth i i think that the country's in a
very sour mood and joe biden
to you know his misfortune is on the
receiving end of that but he did say he
was going to beat the virus
does any of that fall to joe biden for
setting those types of expectations good
question yes uh it's not his fault that
the delta variant was not predicted i
understand that there's two things he
could have done i think he made huge
mistakes by deciding to do this thing
mandate mandate the mass mandate the
vaccine he created an adversarial
relationship with the american public it
wasn't trump against biden it was
mandated against i want to live my own
life so it was freedom verse hey back
off i get it i know the rules so all of
a sudden he creates division there the
other thing he had is remember he got
the 1.9 trillion passed even though
donald trump gave you 800 billion in
december he had to have his 1.9 okay he
got that larry summers says that fueled
inflation then in june he gets a
bipartisan victory he refuses to take a
bow instead he says i'm not going to
pass one without the other one goes
excuse me the 19 republicans who risked
their political future all of a sudden
ago you just out of me then he goes oh
i'm going to walk that back and then he
sat on it for three months then in comes
the evacuation of afghanistan the
biggest military disaster maybe ever in
the history of america and then he's in
september with nothing past he panics
passes this promised to do something
different can't deliver knew he couldn't
deliver because he didn't budge the two
people that needed to budge and that is
mansion and cinema so right now he
refused to take a bow in june screwed up
afghanistan in july and now we're in a
disaster in the fall man made disaster
and the squad hates them now too because
they didn't get what they wanted the
progressives now can't stand him so now
his own party is fractured even more as
a result of his passing the one
promising if you sign this one we'll
pass bill back better no he's not going
to do what he can does buildback better
ever become law i think no no because um
they're not going to get it done before
christmas and the longer anything big
like that languishes
the more it can be attacked so you're
going to go home people are going to
have to deal with omicron over the
holiday you're going to get back january
is anybody in a good mood in january no
not that many people except for me i'll
be very positive
but january is sort of like oh and then
it gets cold and people are gonna dig
their heels in i do think there's one
thing that the administration could have
done differently on vaccines
and that is they should have done more
on international distribution yeah
because where are these variants coming
from right so we one of the ways to deal
with the pandemic is to try to squash it
everywhere by getting
everybody either vaccinated
we did lead the world but they could
have done they could have done even more
imagine if they would have done like a
huge effort a surge all around the world
to get vaccines out there one in terms
of diplomacy instead of the russians and
the chinese being able to use their
vaccines which are not effective they
could have had ours and i think that
looking back that's something they
should have done but it's also something
they probably could do we could have
bribed central america with vax
diplomacy just give them a bunch of
doses say stop the caravans see kamala
should have thought of that right
right hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else